en un largo discurso que duró más del
doble del tiempo que le fue asignado el
presidente nicolás maduro culpó a eeuu
de la crisis en el país y aseguró que
está preparado para resistir sus ataques
dirigidos a expulsarlo del poder lo
mínimo que podemos decir es que ese
impuesto a la desmesura que es el más
terrible de los pecados que parece
haberse apoderado completo de las élites
estadounidense y es por ello que la
república bolivariana de venezuela
reitera la necesidad de reivindicar los
principios de respeto a la soberanía un
poco después juan guaidó se dirigía
también al mundo pero a través de las
redes sociales el líder de la oposición
venezolana reconocido por más de 50
países como el presidente legítimo pidió
a la comunidad internacional mantener la
presión a maduro ya que según él la vía
diplomática está agota hoy les pido a
todos los representantes de los estados
miembros que asuman la responsabilidad
de asistir al gobierno legítimo de
venezuela en su misión de proteger
al pueblo de venezuela de salvar a
venezuela y considerar una estrategia
que contemple escenarios luego de
agotado todas las vías why do reiteró
que su alocución representaba la
venezuela real y señaló el gobierno de
nicolás maduro de violar los derechos
humanos en línea con el informe de la
misión de la onu en ese país que señaló
el presidente venezolano y otros de sus
funcionarios de ser responsables de
delitos de lesa humanidad